oui est officiellement le petit poucet
de la coupe de france de football à
moins de 48 heures de son 32e de finale
contre l'équipe de concarneau et joueur
qui évolue en régionale 3 ont reçu de la
part des sponsors des maillot collector
symbole sur le terrain du statut de plus
petites équipes encore engagées dans la
compétition
je crois que c'est un système de points
et c'est fait le nombre de surprises
réalisé pour l'arrivée jusque là nous
avons éliminé trois équipes qui étaient
d'odile gens dessus et il semble que
nous ayons donc mérité une fois les
maillots distribuer les joueurs se sont
rendus directement stade maurice baquet
futur théâtre de ce 32e de finale pour
effectuer un dernier entraînement
l'occasion pour l'entraîneur de rassurer
ses joueurs avant ce match historique
l'équipe de cours carnot évolué cinq
divisions dessus des yvelinois ont joué
une montagne voulait qu'on pourquoi
voulait construire son risque rien et on
part en part en part de loin on est très
loin de 2 de concarneau qui voulez je
vous dise de plus sûr pas se mettre la
pression
on est très loin de concarneau c'est une
grosse grosse équipe voulez que je vous
dise quoi de plus on se prépare on se
fait plaisir et on verra bien à perdre
pour créer l'exploit les yvelinois
pourront compter sur le soutien du
public plus de 2000 spectateurs sont
attendus dans les gradins coup d'envoi à
15 heures ce samedi 6 janvier